Nick
welcome everyone to today's meeting of
the licensing subcommittee uh just goes
through some housekeeping if the fire
alarm is activated please take the
stairs down to the reception area and
out of the building to the Green in holy
Square which is the assembly point
please do not use the lifts officers
will assist you and advise when it is
deemed safe to return to the council
offices
I would advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
area may have their image captured I
urge anyone's filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if they are children
present I don't think there's anybody
uh does anybody intend to film the
meeting
I'll see anybody there so any member of
the public who objects to the
possibility of being filmed may wish to
take this opportunity to leave the
meeting
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent and that they are not used to
make or receive phone calls while this
meeting is in progress
and moving on to a gender item one
apologies for absence I don't think we
have any apologies so
item two Declaration of interests are
there any Declaration of interests
thank you
um gender item three application for a
new premises license at the uh the 98
Harbor parade Ramsgate I call upon Mr
Joseph katengi the council's senior
litigation a lawyer to explain to the
parties the procedure that we will be
taking during this hearing
Joseph thank you good morning I would
like to confirm that the decision of
this board It's Made In accordance with
the licensing act
2003 and based on the information
presented in in this agenda together
with any variable submissions made today
decision of the board are not
politically based this board must act
impartially and offer a fair and
unbiased hearing of today's application
this subcommittee will give Fair
consideration to everything it hears and
unreached today we are here to consider
an application for a new license at 98
Harbor parade Ramsgate in accordance
with the licensing act 2003 we will hear
the party in the following order
peaceful the license officer present the
report applicants questions for the
licensing officer members of Licensing
Board questions for the last as an
officer the applicants or
representatives to address the committee
licensing officer questions for the for
the applicant or Representative members
of the committee questions for the
applicant once all of the relevance
representations have been made with the
exceptions of the board members that the
Democratic service officer and the legal
officer you will be asked to leave the
chambers so that the lattice in board
can deliberate and come to a decision on
your application this should take around
30 minutes after which you will be
invited back into the chamber for the
announcement of the decision thank you
thank you Mr katangi
um I'd like to stress the importance of
following this hearing procedure and
that there will be an opportunity for
all parties to make a final presentation
after questioning therefore I would
advise all present please follow the
procedure and to respect those speaking
by not interrupting or speaking over
others
okay would the technical support team
manager please present the report
thank you thank you morning everyone
um I just noticed there's a slight error
on the first paragraph there under the
current situation obviously it says
applicants for a variation it's not it's
a new premises license
um the this premises has been operating
for a number of years under various
names with various owners and the
previous owner as you know passed away
last year
um the applicant decided to take over
the premises
um there was discussions as to whether
she took transferred
previous license or whether she took on
a new license but the previous owner
decided to surrender their license so
the applicant has applied for a totally
new premises license
um it was all advertised as is required
under the licensing act we received
um some representations only one of
which is a valid representation under
the licensing act because it was
actually concerning the premises itself
and you know things that happened that
they say they've seen happen there so
that's the one representation that's
before you the police the Environmental
Protection Team and the licensing
officer have agreed various conditions
which are also attached to the agenda
they've agreed them with the applicant
and that's why none of them are here
today because they don't have any
objections to the application
so um thank you chair
would you please present your case
could you just tap on the mic there
yeah the big one that's it
yes to watch um I have read read uh the
condition read the complaint did you
want me to respond to the complaint as
to when you say present your case
it's entirely up to you you can
obviously because you're here to talk
about yeah because I've I've looked at
it to see um the complaint and I have
addressed what I've done about it or
what you know what I've put in place it
is that what you wanted me to go through
okay right right you're right so
um
in December last year I was approached I
was a school teacher for 35 years I was
teaching across the road in Margate and
my partner was cooking Jamaican food
there and when Andy died they were we
were then approached as to whether we
would be interested in taking the
premises on and this was in November oh
no December of last year
um so it was an opportunity that myself
and my partner
um were really interested in and
um decided to go ahead and get a license
with the leaseholder which is the
landlord
um which started from the 1st of
December
um
but I then looked uh shut the premises
for three weeks to make sure everywhere
was clean and to get everywhere safe Etc
because I didn't feel you could open it
there and then after it being three
months under a couple of people managing
it so we shot it for three weeks and
opened up 24th of December on temporary
event notices while I went in the
process of getting my personal license
and the premises license
um and that's where we find ourselves so
um
I gave up job teaching and doing this
full-time taking on taking on the
responsibility the designated premises
supervisor the licensee
um it's and managing the units Etc so
that's where we are that's where we are
today
hey does the licensing team have any
questions for Miss Goodwin no questions
thank you
but members um do you have any questions
for Miss Goodwin no
question no questions yeah I'm just yeah
really just one from me um just with the
old license and the new license were
there any specific changes
yes the word
the word oh thank you
uh slices was operating to sell alcohol
till 2 30 every single morning
but obviously taking over the license I
want to attract more families because
it's it's restaurant food areas so I
didn't see the need to open until 2 30
every morning only required that on a
Friday and a Saturday so the lice the
alcohol license will finish at 11
o'clock
during the week unless it's a bank
holiday or a special event that I could
then apply for an extension so I've
reduced the hours of opening at the
moment it can open at 7 30 in the
morning but we're not opening until 11
up until Easter until we start to get a
bit more tourists available and a bit
more dog walkers available so we've
actually reduced the time that we're
actually selling alcohol
so I think that's quite a significant
change
is there anything else you'd like to add
to Summer
I knew that we inherited quite a lot of
bad feeling with people that have been
licenses and what's gone on in the
property before and when we arrived I
did go around the community introducing
myself to the community and giving them
my phone number if there's any problems
Etc and I've had had conversations with
some of the neighbors and they said that
they've struggled over the last God
knows how many years with problems from
there and and and you know that they
hope that moving forward it would be a
lot more easier than we can work
together so I kind of give them my phone
number and you know just being really
friendly and kind and just inviting them
in and just trying to getting them to
join in as well because the nature of
the place is changing
from a a hardcore music drinking venue
to something that's more about families
and in keeping with the area so I just
wanted to add that I have been around
the community
reaching out because they are strong
they have struggled over the years
okay thank you very much
with the exception of the subcommittee
members the Democratic Services officer
and the legal officer please can I ask
those president to leave the meeting so
that the subcommittee can come to a
decision you'll be invited back for the
decision to be announced